our favorite catwalking company has been
using cloud dlp to automatically redact
and replace
sensitive values from their data but
what about data that they need to
protect but still use
for things like billing stick around and
find out how cloud dlps got them covered
[Music]
[Applause]
kitty cat walks has already implemented
cloud dlp to apply redaction and
replacement
in their issue ticketing system so they
don't inadvertently log any sensitive
information from their customers
their billing department on the other
hand handles tons of credit card numbers
they need to protect that information
but also access those values to process
payments for their premium catwalking
service
so while cloud dlp offers a bunch of
options to help you hide and remove
sensitive values in your data
there's one technique that leverages
encryption to de-identify
and in some cases re-identify those
sensitive values
crypto based tokenization also referred
to as pseudonymization
is a powerful de-identification
technique that uses encryption keys to
replace sensitive data values
with cryptographically generated tokens
this method of de-identification is
especially popular in industries like
finance and healthcare
where protecting data is a matter of
utmost importance
but preserving data utility is still
desired
cloud dlp supports three types of
cryptographic methods
first is deterministic encryption
here the detected data is replaced with
an encrypted value
and prepended with an optional surrogate
annotation
this method supports most input types
and is authenticated
which makes it the most recommended
tokenization solution
the next method is format preserving
encryption
fpe like deterministic encryption
fpe will replace the value of an
encrypted string
except it's going to be the same length
and use the same character set as the
original value
this is the way to go if you need to
retain support for any legacy data
systems that have strict
length character set requirements the
third method
is cryptographic hashing here dlp
replaces sensitive data with a hashed
value
unlike the other two methods
cryptographic hashing uses a one-way
token so it can't be reversed it's the
perfect solution if you want each unique
value to be transformed into a
corresponding unique
hash value but don't necessarily want it
to be reversible
more on that later one huge factor that
sets all three of these apart from most
other de-identification techniques is
that they allow us to securely
de-identify data
while retaining its referential
integrity referential integrity allows
records to maintain the relationship to
one another
even after being individually
de-identified
for example if we have this table of
data with cryptographic hashing applied
to one of its fields
using the same cryptographic key each of
the unique values will have a consistent
transformed value this means that data
can be de-identified for security or
compliance reasons
but still used for business operations
and analytical workflows such as joining
across tables
or aggregating data so another powerful
feature of tokenization is the ability
to reverse the encryption
to re-identify the data since
deterministic encryption
and format preserving encryption use a
symmetric encryption key to tokenize
data
the same key can be used to essentially
undo the de-identification
to reveal the original value the option
to re-identify
expands utility of cloud dlp so that
data can be securely obscured
and readable only by systems authorized
to access the encryption key
and the output value let's see how the
dlp api handles tokenization by looking
at this request
from a node.js app in this example
we're going to apply format preserving
encryption to the credit card number
field of this sample csv
data the outset to the variable mycsv
this is the request object that will
send to the de-identified content
function
first we want to specify the csv data
that we want to scan
in the de-identification configuration
we'll indicate a few things
here in the transformations array is
where we indicate each of the
transformations we'd like to apply
in this case we just want to target the
info type credit card number and provide
an fpe configuration for format
preserving encryption
there we provide a wrapped key which
i've contained in the variable
my wrap key and the cloud kms key we
used to wrap it in the form of a kms
resource name
that i threw into the variable my key
name we'll also specify that we want to
transform our data using a numeric
alphabet
and provide a surrogate info type string
that will be appended to each
value the response of this function will
include the data we provided
in the request except the credit card
numbers replaced with an encrypted
string
and prepended the surrogate info type we
specified
as you can see each unique value in our
original data remains unique
after transformation with its
referential integrity intact
in a larger data set we'd still be able
to analyze the data without accessing
the sensitive values
so how about re-identification the
re-identify content function takes this
request object
it looks similar to the de-identified
content request except
we'll be passing our de-identified data
as long as the surrogate
info type and the encryption key we
provide matches what we use to tokenize
our data
the result will be our original data
with the sensitive values revealed
now that kitty catwalks have added
crypto based tokenization to their dlp
know-how
their security and compliance teams can
sleep soundly knowing that their
customer billing information
is well protected on their systems next
time
we'll take what they've learned so far
and see how they'll use it to construct
dlp templates so that they can reuse
inspection and de-identification rules
across
different systems and processes see you
[Music]
soon
[Music]
you